you see a lot of women they will all go
for the same man not because he's
actually doing anything and i'm talking
about the everyday man that you see on
the road that maybe isn't financially
viable he's not doing anything but women
either got money muscles or
frame or game what's that i don't i'm
not a woman don't go after a man with
nothing he's either got money muscles
framework yeah well it's usually a frame
or game so what's they're getting
they're getting they're getting from
this they're getting finessed in this
day and age framework yeah it's
anyone
pretty
flash um
and
i think and then when it starts to go
left
they blame everybody by themself and
it's like but you are you chose you're
looking at him you're seeing his
behavior and the way he speaks doesn't
match up with what he's
what he's saying so
what he's doing sorry so for me like my
dad always told me if a man wants to do
something he will do it if he tells you
he's gonna do and he doesn't do it he
didn't want to do it in the first place
he's just trying to satisfy you so you
can not to be rude but be quiet stop
going on that just
be chill
and he didn't say exactly like that my
dad wouldn't speak like that but
if a man tells you he's gonna do
something and he doesn't do it he never
intended to do it in real terms
and if he does it and those um actions
match up to what he's saying then you
you need to
look at that and appreciate it for what
it is
you know so i think as women we over
romanticize people that talk to talk
some kind of talk they can show off a
little bling but we're not looking at
the facts the facts are this guy is not
viable he he's desirable maybe image
wise
but in real terms it's not a lot it
won't last
do you know a lot of this stuff what
you're saying comes from i'm thinking
about oh wait that's why i've seen this
in a disney movie but um i think that's
a big issue at the moment where
our childhood
is affecting a lot of our behaviors as
an adult because
we're not unlearning what we've seen
does that make sense no it's a
generation that's changing though it's
changing now because kids nowadays
everything's on demand so whatever they
want they're going to get it whereas for
us
we grew up with that whole
fairy tale fairy tale we're protected
we're not waiting for it yeah we're not
holding certain things at certain times
to stop us from doing things which is
and that's why when men say that now
we get backlash from women because it's
like we're breaking your dreams that the
dreams that you've been sold for so long
right and that you've held on to yeah
like there's a lot of men just like
saying you know what ladies i know you
got sold that but this is what it's
really like no you're misogynist just
like no
we're just telling you how it is you
know what's crazy every time a man has a
standard women shame him for it
i like if a guy says i don't i don't
date fat woman he's fat phobic if he
says i don't
date
um if i don't date fat woman he's fat
phobic if i don't date older women he's
ages
i don't if i don't take if i don't date
singles single mothers misogynist yeah
it's like every time a man has a
standard he's shamed for it but women we
can say oh i want a guy that makes this
much money i want him a guy that's this
tall i want a guy that does this this
and this no one says anything but it's
like women as soon as a man has a
standard they automatically shame him
it's as if we're supposed to just
whatever women say we're just supposed
to go along with it i'm forced into like
yes
oh i like that too like we know what we
like and we don't like yeah yeah i like
that yeah
because i don't want to take the
backlash of being called fat phobic
whatever phobic misogynist and da da but
now what is happening is men are saying
you know what you don't care cool that's
what you want but we're going to say
i just would never shame a guy into like
because i feel like why would you want
to beg someone to like you like i've had
guys tell me like they're just not into
like ginger it's like tall like pale
like there's another thing they're into
like tanner darker girls yeah and i'm
like i'm not gonna be mad at you but
that's just a preference what's wrong
with having a preference yeah everything
that i listed is preference it's a
preference yeah and not everybody is for
everybody so for me i if a guy says oh i
don't like i don't know i don't like
girls that are over i don't know five
foot three then okay like that why would
i be offended by your height you're
hypothetic no no because you know women
say they want a guy that's six foot or
they're above six foot and that's highly
um you know unrealistic
i said all the time like you're five
foot two you want a six foot five man
you know you're climbing a tree when
he's kissing you he's going what are you
doing like
it doesn't make sense so whenever like
my friend's like oh i can't date a guy
that's like my hat i'm like babes
imagine yeah
you're wearing your heels and you're
tired you have a pole you can just lean
on him like it's just i'm just yo i
never thought of him like it's it's much
more convenient than you think it is you
just have to
step outside but where does that i don't
have that problem as a six foot two male
1 where does that start
where does that standard come from
because it's like saying oh i want a guy
to be six foot or above like it's
unrealistic but where does that come
from it's because women have slept with
so many people nowadays that they get a
guy that's a certain height and
they'll sleep with guys that like so if
a girl is a five or six she can sleep
with a guy that's an eight nine or ten
but he's not sticking around
and so the guys that are six four six
five like they give their pick of the
litter why would they pick you but
that's the thing though how did two men
get idolized as you're the gold
biology it's a biological thing yeah so
we're still rooted in biology so
um
we're biologically predispositioned to
like taller men because they could take
care of us
so if there's biological reasons we feel
the way we feel we can't just undo them
but the problem is is that women think
they deserve more than they are and i
like i see girls all the time i'll see
them reject guys and i'm like honestly
he's better looking than you
mm-hmm
do you think that beauty standards are
biological
yes it's so it's facial symmetry so like
when i'm ranking people one to ten i use
kevin samuel's scale a lot and like
because i'll do it in videos i'll be
like okay that girl's with that or that
or that and it's based on your facial
symmetry so if you're an eight nine or
ten that means you can get a modeling
contract sevens but they don't give five
six is pretty cute
yeah but it's when i say that it's like
i think different cultures have
different beauty standards yeah yeah i'm
saying so it's like
um if you were to go to south america
and go to a tribe in south america right
they've had their beauty standard within
their tribe for thousands of years so
their beauty centers are well as what a
woman is beautiful isn't the same as the
western world no i think it's somewhat
stan like i think facial symmetry is
standard no matter what about body type
yeah body type um i i want to say it's
still the big hips is like for birthing
children big boobs is for for
for feeding children for feeding
children small waist
no there's some biological reason behind
a small waist and i can't remember what
it is there must be but there's
biological reasons behind a big ass
there is especially for black men
that's cultural
and i've seen that we've seen that for
thousands of years you can hypnotize a
man just by having it like yeah what's
my facial symmetry like
off like just what i would give you yes
oh
tell me if you do this no it's fine like
i i i'm expecting lower than
um i'd give you five six okay
i i think i called that before can i
just ask what country you're from if you
don't mind me me it's zimbabwe
it was either south african or zimbabwe
um
and i was asking that because you would
talk about beauty standards
and i think like you're saying it's
different everywhere so
and even in different african cultures
is completely different you've got like
some parts of africa they want slim
women maybe big hips maybe not it just
depends on maybe the tribe for example
and there's some places where they want
women with big hips they might just be
big and that's what they like so i think
that where we live in the western world
it's like i feel like we're being
conditioned to expecting that oh this
person should be like this or this
person should be like that but we're so
diverse now
that there are going to be people for
example in london that prefer this and
then there's going to be a different set
of people that prefer that and that is
because it's biologically within us so i
don't think it's like
i don't know that's why i find it
difficult
when
people
kind of shame
other
women for whatever they have for example
you could be shamed for being skinny you
could be shamed for being fat you could
be shameful not having an ass you could
be ashamed for
sorry do you notice the language you're
using
you're ashamed but men
no one's going to say oh men are shamed
for being short men are shamed for being
i was i was getting there i was getting
there
i was going to say the short men are
suffering
they are suffering
and bald men
oh yeah
for some reason but i don't think it's
shaming i just think it's what is like i
just think if you're not realistic
you're going to be delusional
no it's shaming no i don't think it's
shaming i think the dating market is
harsh what people want to date and you
should be selective in who you date and
there's no there's nowhere in the world
and if you can pull me an exact tribe
that is active in 2022 you could show me
and prove me wrong but that that wants
obese women
oh there are tribes where they feed
women milk to make them bigger
okay so
more here
for example men feed women
so that
other men can't have them that's one
part i have actually i've heard that i
have heard that as a form of makeup
really really sad it's
but like in terms of like when you're
saying shaming
me sitting here today
three years ago i was a size six and i
was skinny as hell
i looked fine on the outside
so for whatever reason people still try
to move to me but i'm just not i'm not
interested in men like that either way
um
are you gay no i'm not gay i just
i am not gay um
but like i said i'm just not ready like
yeah and i think because we'll talk
about dating online as well and i've
seen some
i've seen some things i'm just like yeah
no i'm okay i'm okay i'm actually happy
i found the people though in africa that
feed people where
um they're called uh the la
la blue
in
sega
spell it i just want to go yeah l eb
l-o-u-h
and it's saying uh the islamic republic
of mauritania west african nation with
the population more than four million
people a country that is deeply
patriarchal in society in which women
and girls are taught that they are
inferior to men and must please men in
order to have a fulfilling life one
manifestation of this culture is the
standard of beauty for women which
emphasizes obesity as a sign of wealth
status and
because back desirability if you've got
a man that is big
you're eating well yeah i would say i'm
sorry go ahead now i was just going to
say you're eating well so that must show
you have some sort of money in some sort
of wealth yeah i would say in um
and i can't
completely speak but just from what i
see and what i hear um latin people
experience like their abuelos would be
like have you eaten here e-e-e and
they'll feed them because it's just part
of their culture to
have those hips for the kids and be
ready to
um
have kids and whatnot no that's so
interesting i've just never heard of it
yeah that's so interesting
but even in general like you see when
someone is really really slim
the minute they start to put on weight
people look at you like oh
you're looking good what's going on
but it's like
i'm still the same person hello i think
there's a
i think the culture changes because i
remember when i was younger yeah
light-skinned black guys were in style
those are desirable black mm-hmm
right that's what happened when i now
it's like the dark skinned black guy
yeah and i'm like i'm good do you know
what i'm saying but like like just
preferences change for that time i think
sometimes to go back to what the two
things you said one you said um when
someone um
is gaining weight you're like oh they're
eating good
i wanna know
from everybody's like perspective
whenever you see
a celebrity when they start off they're
small and then once they get in the game
and whatnot they start gaining weight
what
do you guys say
it depends i feel like if you're a big
bigger person losing weight sometimes
it's scary
okay not like that if they're if they're
small because it's something that me and
my
we like we see and it's like funny
because you have said it when they're
small at first and then like when they
first start out whatever it is music or
acting or whatever it is like rihanna
how she went really slim and then she
came back to
no no so what i'm trying to get is that
um
it's a funny thing like when you see
somebody at first they're like oh
they're slim and then they go pools just
so that we um
i'm trying to think there was
there was someone i saw when i went home
i cannot remember like an actor but the
thing is when uh
when like a famous person is small and
they get money they're like oh they
eating good because they got money now
they ain't good they so it was just that
that i heard you say and that's
something that you know you're no longer
struggling basically you got money now
you can you can eat good you can afford
to eat good you know what i see that in
wrappers mm-hmm i've seen rappers like
you see they start off they're not
they're not necessarily skinny skinny
mm-hmm but like
you just see this
yeah
and you're like wait wait they're all
there
and you know as you see them on social
media as well they'll be in all these
nice restaurants you'll be in all these
like different places and you're like oh
okay that's why you're living the soft
life that's a sign that like someone has
money is
they eating good like you can eat now
eat
and then another thing that you said
earlier you were talking about fairy
tales and how it has um
how it has like gave us this image of
relationships i think another thing that
has given us this image of relationship
is a popular story in the bible is ruth
and boaz i think that's one thing that
um
was taught from a young age wait for
your boas wait for your boss wait for
your boss and they didn't tell us about
like oh
ruth was actually working i didn't hear
about like the real story until i got
older like oh ruth wasn't just sitting
around waiting for her man to come sweep
her off her feet like no she was like
out in the field working like being in
places where
her like man could uh could see her yeah
i could see her and it's like man and
it's like they
partially gave us a story to put in our
image you just have to wait and they
will come to you you don't have to be
anywhere don't put yourself in no
position and everything will work out
and it's like man we were like given
a false image of what
what we need to do to be in a position
to get because you've been saying that
now like you see that even when people
are trying to date oh
i'm i'm looking for a guy with money
i'm thinking where you going to find him
he's not you have to be in that
environment he's not looking for you
he's not looking for you but you have to
be if you really want him you have to be
in that environment you have to either
be working where he's working or
in the social environments that they're
in to get that kind of person so so what
do you think when women are in that
environment what do you think the
competitive nature is with women like
that around those men
i feel like it is yeah i feel like
you're gonna go into that
if you're looking for that man with six
figures seven figures
you cannot care because
if you start caring
and i think i was gonna say there's a
there's a thing that women in that
environment have that the average woman
does not and there's a level of
refinement like when they go out they
don't wear they don't go to certain
shops and buy certain clothes and have a
certain look they they kind of hold a
bit of modesty about them things for the
man to kind of find out whereas this
culture that we have in the general
mainstream is give everything up show
everything yeah and
um kind of be vulgar and be open about
certain things
it's those things that the man doesn't
know he will pursue do you get one
because he doesn't know it so he has to
find out and in that kind of environment
from what i think i'm not in that
environment but
there's a it's femininity that comes
into play so being a bit more reserved
um
talking and having certain types of
conversation so gossip is not
conversation that would be happening in
that environment swearing and being so
abrupt you know come you know what they
would call as traditional a traditional
woman i guess do you know what i mean
so yeah i don't know i i'm not there so
what can i say society sorry it hasn't
been away from the traditional woman for
whatever reason it doesn't like in the
sense of that's why you've got sierra
twerking yeah but she was probably my
opinion is in that environment what um
what we're talk what we're talking about
so where the higher paid uh desirable
men are those types of women are you
know what we would call traditional more
reserved and the people like sierra and
cardi b are in our arena and that it
almost makes it a pool
because the majority of people are
trying to appease that social norm of
sierra and cardi b so while all of us
are focusing on that the the the
minority that is in in our in our um
in our community are actually in that
arena with the high value men do you get
what i mean so if we were in a different
country and a different culture it would
be totally different certain countries
the way that we behave here is totally
unacceptable for a woman
yeah so
it's a big part is the development of
birth control in the 1960s that's why
you see women
acting the way they do today they don't
have a consequence anymore
because they used to have to get married
young otherwise they'd probably get
pregnant
but now it's like there's basically
there's two types of men that women go
for there's the alphas and the betas and
birth control gives them the option to
hook up with the guy
um for the short term like fun guy
without any consequences and then marry
the long guy later after after they've
been ran through in their 20s